we're alive hey everybody what's going
on welcome to stream Coco you guys could
clap back there come on clap a little
bit energy really excited today we've
got guy brought him on the show he's got
a great new show coming up on April 5th
called
talk show the game show which takes two
of my favorite formats and creates some
kind of Frankenstein Ian comedy monster
okay
destroy stealing a body blow body blow
and today we're playing this game called
everything which is gonna be super weird
I rolled around as a donkey for five
minutes before
that's exciting oh yeah well why are we
gonna play that also I wore this shirt
which I feel like kind of has everything
on it that's like reading a teddy bear
getting [ __ ] up but I know it's
happening here's a skateboard involved
hello everyone hello twitch hello
YouTube what's happening on the subject
of donkeys rolling around have you
played any of the goat simulation games
yeah Andy Richter loves being a goat
so who knew I'm gonna put your name in
okay you know that's that way I can't be
responsible for yeah you got you were
the head writer of x-play you guys
remember x-play I was the head writer of
the next play so I know a lot about
video games right seven years ago you
really know like what Max Payne I love
it and that's and you know now and you
you bet on the Mindy project which is
fantastic yes you've gone on to bigger
things not necessarily better because I
love to explain no no bigger things it
was wonderful having a little show where
no one was watching so we could just do
whatever we want is much like this is
great you feel are how you feel our joy
/ our pain so your do you want to play
just get in here yeah yeah I think we're
just a dot of light this is gonna be a
super trippy game this evolution is this
spory
yes you know what it might be spore -
electric Boogaloo I think exactly it's
asking existential question I think
we're a space sperm right now
now we're a cat or a space cat on the
moon we're a space cat on them on earth
and there's a giant placed PSN logo
exactly
I love the Roman Wyatt this is why
that's not how cats move this game is
not super person all right now you'll
see the show so tell us about it okay I
talk talk show the game show premiering
April 5th o 9 central it's basically a
talk show where you score points not
unlike the coding program perfect where
you score points by doing the sorts of
things you're supposed to join a talk
show like name-dropping
some of my very good friends like Wanda
Sykes and Moby are on the points point
exactly points that's how it works I
love it and then after people's
interviews they're evaluated by a
fabulous panel of judges you do like a
post mortem of their interview and
absolutely it is real-time reaction
videos so if people do a terrible job
I'll head over to that thing over there
that white that weird white thing I
don't understand why I'm not like you're
supposed to be like running into
anything I've not gotten the point at
least like rub your butt on him or
something if you hold if you have
actually go real fast okay hold X oh you
now you're really rolling
see I think you could talk to this tree
wait oh wait oh my go back to the we can
talk to the video thoughts I did warn
you that this game was insane a lot like
my shirt Chris whacks the cat is rolling
around on the ground okay are you not
watching this you just have the chat on
with no no visuals you know you asked me
what we're looking at I want to eat a
stag I very much I like games that
require you to eat and sleep yes I
simply have a budget seems wake over to
that weird star thing I think that's
something I like games with gardening's
and budget
like to know the best thing about being
a head writer of x-play I would love to
know the best every year at e3 I could
just go to the Natsume and say whatever
toy you have hey we're talking to a
stick alright there we go like up for
others at this thing
Mik Adil oh you're watching stream Coco
with guy brought him I got any shocks
for the game show coming up April 5th
and we're playing a game I'm sorry this
is e this is literally wrong right
exactly I feel like if we were on Molly
this would smooth us out and we're not
is like the component you need exists
10/10 IGN says best game of the year
we'll see yin yang spilled milk out of
his or her nose that's wonderful there
you go wait so did you tell me how you
came up with talks to the game show I
was at a stage show first yes so 15
years ago I was in a van if you want me
to take over at some point just let me
know I should be able to do both of
these things at the same time 15 years
ago that's in a van on the way to a quiz
bowl tournament in the Midwest oh my
goodness talking to my best friend and
we were talking about how when you're on
a talk show there's a right and wrong
way to do it until we started just
joking about talk show the game show
about how there should be like a 1970s
style talk show up being that game shows
yeah the people from Three's Company
could be on and then for 10 years I did
nothing with that and then I didn't have
a job and I had left Chelsea Lately and
I was sad why does this glowing thing
not do any I'm not sure you know I think
you press in the r3 button oh I think
you can growl or something here here
I'll go over it so keep going
so I how long is this van ride was this
just an hour's no it was like a ride
from Minneapolis to Chicago so like a
town that's a long ride and then enough
to hatch a show yes and then
I after I left Chelsea Lately I didn't
know what I was doing that myself and I
miss talk shows so this is we're just
listening the trees complain I know I
kind of love it
what WTF pardon my letters is up with
this game um but I like came up with
rules and then I just asked the improv
if I could do it and they were like sure
but not in the main room sure in the
hallway and I started doing it was
really fun we got really great people to
do it live Academy Award winners Tony
winner Marissa Jaret Winokur Diablo Cody
lots of people with Daytime Emmys those
are yellow statues the same that's just
the same exactly you could still melt it
down and sell it for Coke uh not that I
would know that was a very specific
thing I just said
well the the show like was like
successful when people had a really good
time and then eventually Wanda Sykes and
her producing partner became aware of it
and we're like let's turn this into a
real show yeah where you can make money
instead of just doing this for free
everybody's and so when you when you
were adapting it from the stage to TV
what was that what were some of the
challenges I mean besides being horribly
nervous Wow first of all I'm a goddamn
profession the show was pretty produced
to begin which like ran at like a clean
forty four minutes and had to trim it
down to 24 damn so there were some
efficiencies found redundancies as they
say in the yeah office and I had to
figure out how to deal with guests who
weren't just people I already knew right
I feel bad that you're just clicking
through those dialogues considering
those dialogues are the only game we're
getting well yeah I I will say I just
wanted to be able to sing I wanted to
get to know where you could sing to
other animals now because that's what I
did in the three minutes I found this
game in preparations and that's one of
those IBEX is what's an ibex
I don't know antelope well they're all
they're all so I'm really scared of you
because you're going to eat them no yeah
but can I eat them dude I'm upside down
oh by the way it looks like I'm just
like fully erect at all times here
what's happening there's an excited cat
can I eat this thing or what
oh man you would you would have skewered
this unexplained I feel like yes the
thing is is like at least it does
something on x-play we always had those
games that leg
we're just broken just I feel like steam
is like a quarter of the things on Steam
yeah and you're like this is a this is
like a screen saver with some extra
interactivity you still play to do news
I do but I play a very boring involved
video games let's hear it oh I like a
nice Europa Universalis 4 oh my god I'm
very slow very political game oh I've
heard of that game there's this thing on
steam it's new thing on Steam it's
called like spore on LSD this is Dennis
this is definitely spawn LSD it's like
it's a real-time strategy game but you
like oh you build trees and some of they
make ghosts and they fight with the
other goes that game is so much fun like
what does it call again it's like it's
like seven letters long and there's an
enema fee I forget Nuvi wow that sounds
awesome
yes but it's it's really cool it's
basically I hope next spring is as sunny
as this if not I'll be absolutely
furious I mean I love the spirit of this
game I love it too you know we also have
this game where the monsters loaded up
where we could just fight each other as
giant monsters if this gets but I like
being on this adventure but the steam
game that I don't know the name of it's
essentially like Starcraft but with
trees and ghosts and like knots do you
guys know what it's trees and ghosts
start crap with trees and ghosts anybody
came out anybody hello lady reading
comments send nudes you know here's the
thing about sending nudes if you're
gonna say send nudes you got to be
specific
cuz I will send you some nudes why to
see you know what I'm saying like
they're just a lot of like of those
Donald Trump statues like the Donald
Trump that's the kind of notes I said
nothing it is horrifying and disgusting
even just how small his hands
Xavier Rao would like to ask why
this bald guy sound like a [ __ ] because
I'm a homosexual
I have a gay voice it is part of my
culture but the capacity of the Internet
to point out how fat and gay I am is one
of the things I truly love about it yeah
it's it's deepest power your most
maximum weight we can join other
mountain lines here now shits about to
get real weighted by pressing are these
them are these other mountain lions no
yes oh I'm joined to work you must be
close to another mountain lion oh so
when my niece was like 7 she became
obsessed with this MMORPG that was made
by the Department of the Interior about
wolf conservation where you play it as a
wolf
it was the most boring thing ever it was
also slightly captivating I got really
involved in this game called Jenny
nation-states or something where it was
like a text-based game but wonderful
similar where it was like basically
promotion for this guy's book about like
politics but I was Rica's you make
choices and that affects the people and
your in your nation that's wonderful
I for like three years I played this and
it was just it was a fascinating to me
there's nothing more satisfying than
playing some like technically like 10
years ago yes right and just being like
I don't care it's a good game
this this what is do you think this is a
dear what is this it's a dear it's a doe
by the way right talking about ray a
drop of Golden so there we go turn me
now I'm gonna be furious until it
changes alright I want to join some
other mountain lines here but I'm not
sure where to go or do you want to take
over yes we find some other mountain
lines so we have we press square we can
I just feel so alone as a mountain lion
somebody asked bald homosexual half life
3 jokes half life 3 thoughts
that's wouldn't say look I haven't I
haven't been in that world since Orange
Box in frankly I liked team fortress
more yes I agree or portal portal is so
wonderful wonderful Stephen Merchant in
Portal 2 is a national treasure and I
know it's not our nation but like
he's a treasurer of Great Britain
hey mein name Nani we're playing this
game called everything and now by the
way I'm kind of into this rolling thing
I was I was against it and initially but
I'm I can't though you found so many
good things well I it was all luck it's
just I look I'm a lucky mountain lion
exactly here at the Animal Kingdom
Olympics you have the majestic mountain
lion going for gold here on the tumbling
there
well played ooh York exactly wait are
these its I will say one gripe straight
out of the box is it's hard to tell the
animals from each other yes you know
like get a little colorful with it the
palettes so dull here but you know more
brightly color so I can see the other
mountain there's something magical and
terrible about living in this world
where all of the cool games are made by
one dude in his or her that's sure like
apartment as opposed to you know the
franchise games that take nine years
that's true Team Fortress 2 best game
ever we do so much fun my favorite video
game ooh
oh god of all time that's a tough one
honestly probably going to be SSX 3 SSX
3 very satisfying in the game very
satisfied the answer is Wow I lost a
good like three years of my life to work
I couldn't I couldn't play Wow because
it's like I know my limit you can't
smoke half a crack rock you know you
can't just dip your toe in the world of
warcraft you got to go all-in
well you gotta go well the answer for me
is what did you do in 2005 well Wow and
get take out a short autobiography
that's a short after it's just very yeah
oh wait a second
oh here we go whoo there's love in the
air is this are you controlling both of
them yes oh dude oh you can go collect a
bunch of other mountain lions
and do nothing with that this is not
destroying our brain right and some
weird way I think I mom oh dude this is
great you got three turning very
Katamari Damacy Okada Mario was a that
was a great game
yeah it was the saddest thing is when
you have a game to look at your Posse
put the thing like with calamari or um
over Assassin's Creed we die this game
oh my god what's opens up games and then
of sequels innovative in nowhere right
exactly yes I agree I agree yeah you
gotta raise the game or make them - so
you got a you raise the bar this is
great look at wait how do I so you just
when there's like hearts around them
that's oh
look at hear my roar this is great oh my
god feel so powerful and weirdly
pathetic how did you find that I just
get another one
I'm not exactly sure now what do we do
other mountain lions or did you see
where they were you just kind of came
upon them this is you should be allowed
to eat things I think so I there's a lot
of things here I wanted it's time to
just constantly lunch it what if but
when you start attacking things that
gets hyper-realistic
just blood on the screen and people are
screaming I just finished playing
Resident Evil 7 which was like wait
where are the zombies now yeah well let
me tell you it was a very Texas Chainsaw
Massacre in a house the second boss was
this woman where her engine room is
basically a beehive and it just mutant
bees dude out of the that you know it's
like love the way all video games are
gonna build to talk to the psyche of a
14 yes whatever is you most look a be we
would punch a tree if we could punch a
tree yes not an option not an option I
can roll by a tree defines so wait so
talk to the game show now talk to me
about alcohol consumption okay
so I'll talk to the game show you can
get three points for two points in three
points I forget for drinking alcohol on
stage and it does lead to a
the charming show though there were
honestly occasions with things baby got
a little out of hand okay and it was fun
and awesome like at the end of our first
week of taping we had a certain CNN
correspondent on who had her fill of
wine whoa that guy goes home pint of ice
cream Rosie
every night I know he does and we
honestly had to be like alright maybe
next week we shouldn't produce them
towards drinking quite so much three is
a lot of points for doing something
that's really fun well and I also do my
best to try to keep up with my guests
oh um and that can be a mistake though
it is super fun to be at a job where you
can cut in just get drunk yes most of my
jobs I don't think you were proud at all
I think that the rest of us haven't
probably don't have jobs like that
seems like you've cracked the code what
were some of the biggest Jody Katie's
guy from Chelsea Lately
yeah mini-project somebody was saying
like we should just go as far as we can
I'm always amazed by those people who
just went on minecraft and just explored
as far as they could yeah until the
machine broke right they are heroes and
our those are true American heroes yes
this is the real heroes like Lewis and
Clark it's a Minecraft that's a resume
builder yeah me we'll just go straight
and just see we could we have a lot of
bats who the artist is trying to give us
help he understands this game is this
find a mandala icon to get further well
that's where the artist is all over this
just like a Hindu or Buddhist lesson
yeah basically become one with the
mountain lion but I feel like most video
games are like a Buddhist lesson alright
so much time fighting with it and then
you're finally like oh this is pointless
right right you see through the veil of
reality yeah one of the best experience
is while working at x-play was
RPGs I know there were all of these
people posting about oh whoa what the
[ __ ] is going on I don't know I'm
growling at all these things and they
all they're mad at you they're mad
they're running away I can't eat them
hey guys hey just hey Eric does anybody
know how to eat stuff on here
what 14-year old boy wants a scary old
lady vagina B I don't know I think but
it you know it's a comment on I don't
they don't consciously want it they
subconsciously want it yes because they
are deeply into the V at that point in
time these everywhere not just on that
cute girl on the volleyball team and
they're scared of the V yeah there's you
know that's it's the dread in the
yearning it's the yearning for a V but
the dread of the V yes you know it's so
it's a it's really it's a it's a
dichotomy within their soul that that
creates common internal conflict which
tears every fourteen-year-old boy apart
another world and rubs
I can't another world wants to know how
you got to work with Conan I would like
to know that too
well how do I got to work with Conan yes
I was an intern and they made a mistake
and hired me which was obviously I'm
getting paid now to roll around with a
bunch of mountain top the guy Branum
which is pretty great all right here's
there's the thing up here uh yeah that
was that was basically yet and they also
this is actually a hilarious thing they
didn't think nobody thought the internet
was gonna go anywhere so they were like
do you want to write a blog no one else
wants to do it I was like sure and then
cut to Malik we've won an Emmy our
department is huge and we do all this
crazy [ __ ] it is like I remember being
follow your dreams kids even if you
don't know your dreams are a g4 we were
always like oh nobody wants to watch
gameplay on television right and then
now
PewDiePie yes wasn't like a you know an
industry until reason right exactly not
which is 60 million subscribers could
you put the camera anymore lower I could
I can just stand up so it's exactly
crotch level we gotta see the TV dude
yes and plus we want to show off our
beautiful knees look at these needs I'm
known for my these are a bunch of
great-looking knees oh my god so what
are your favorite moments of so you're
obviously you shot the entire season we
shot the
tire season it premieres by the way
April Fenton says it's untrue untrue TV
talk show the game show the game has we
great people on it uh and what are your
summer some your favorite moments spoil
you know spoiler alert what are some of
your favorite moment that happened well
the best thing on the show was they're
people you expect to be good at talk
shows like Wendy mclendon-covey from the
Goldbergs is like a great improviser and
super super funny and she's done the
live show I knew she would be good but
there was some real surprises like
Rashad Jennings who was running back for
the New York Giants won and was just
charming and so funny and amazing Moby
came on and was super super oh my god
Motors got a great rest have you been to
movies rest I have not been but he's
brought me vegan cookies are so good
that's awesome
it was amazing Kobe seems like a cool
dude plus I think he lives like in a
castle nearby heard this I don't know
what the story I think he just lives in
a castle over in Silver Lake castles in
Silver Lake
well Moby has a castle it's all that
South Side money
going to the south side color blind
white electronic music art yeah that's
like Moby would be kind of a great guy
yes no he was super super funny awesome
wanda sykes was great of course and is
one of the executive producers but she
also got super competitive about other
people being like she was very worried
about other people out scoring her after
she had done this really yes interested
so that was super fun I wonder that's
just like a like Hearst ant like her
stand up like baccarat like cutthroat
stand up absolutely that's so fun at the
end of the game she wants to win we had
one show that just ended in a
disqualification whoa um there was I
won't say who but there was one person
who just couldn't stop saying eating
that [ __ ] it finally became he was red
carded oh because you also can
placed in a penalty box or red-carded
out of the game that's crazy why it's so
what what are the stakes like what are
people what do people win okay besides
obviously fame fortune bragging rights
understandable in in the live show it
was always just like a Starbucks gift
card and second place always got gay
porn they would not let me do that yes
but uh we we sent people home with a
dishwasher a front door a garbage
disposal there we go lots of really
wonderful practical things that you do
need in your home I got to feel like
that that's it feels like that's a fun
kind of like like ironic throwback to
like the 70s games like you know a game
yeah winning like a or like a vacation
or winning like we were deeply like
deeply wanted to give away a three-day
two-night vacation Oakland California
[Laughter]
beautiful thing quotes I'm sorry it
didn't work out that's that's awesome
how are how is now how is this might be
a little - making the sausage for people
at home but how were a love song so we
all love sausage it's delicious unless
your mobiie sausage yes how was how was
true to work with Oh were they great
Howard like censors like all that stuff
did you find it was hard to get stuff no
I mean the thing is uh in this vast
media age we live in
everybody has to have five jobs like
everybody I would write for the Mindy
project I do other things and I have the
show and true is very much excited about
being a place where people do the stuff
that they want to do and love today is
awesome so like they just started a new
show with this guy Prentiss penny who is
the showrunner of insecure oh yes look
as a show where he like like shows you
how to upgrade your life
and true is really really awesome and
just wanted to sort of like make the
show they had seen kill how do you kill
things I don't know someone explain to
us how to kill things I'm really trying
to kill something by the way I think
it's getting dark in this game there are
some games where I do not need realistic
day to night it's just depressing it's
like I've been playing this game in game
for four days oh here is a very
lame video game taste that I have oh
that's not I love playing tycoon games
like a six-year-old and like
rollercoaster tycoon like not so much
that but there is this game called game
developer tycoon that I play obsessively
where you wait I don't know how does
that actually work like you like to
decide what kind of game like how good
your development and all of that super
boring no it sounds kind of fun we
played farming simulator oh really fun
that game was really really fun I'm so
slow bought the farm simulator off of
steam and it was terrible because I
loved a bit farm simulator like the
Harvest Moon games back in the day
pretty good oh I hear that there's
there's something valley out now that's
like American Harvest Moon and that's
kind of great whoa but I don't want to
play a farming game where I learn to
love the people around me and know their
birthday right yes I am NOT Japanese I
want to play a game where I book I'm
wealthy I want to live out my dreams of
massive wealth and game development yeah
somebody wants to know what my studio is
called I believe you mean my gaming
studio I usually name them after like
Greek or Aztec gods or a dirty word
stardew valley should I get started that
way starting Valley all right everyone
that's two valleys stardew valley should
I get started Bally jacket Wakko we're
playing now we're playing this game
called everything we're so far were a
bunch of mountain lions and guy Branum
is here from mini-project Chelsea Lately
and his brand-new show talks on the game
show
giant promoting right now yes comes out
April 5th at 10 p.m. that's right with a
splashy and exciting show hey do you
like talk shows hey do you like game
shows yes gonna love talking you want to
know who was like who's great was John
Salley yes but I really feel like an
athlete who has then become like a
broadcaster yes maybe like the perfect
combination yeah like a Charles Barkley
like yeah
I agree because they kind of don't give
a [ __ ] at all Oh super funny turn Osama
just made a season pass for my show
yes Steve oh thank you so much that's
really great yes fine afternoon it is a
good time to kick back and remember how
little time I left I have you know what
I am this is my this is my mission
statement right here this is I love that
this is so full of philosophy at a
certain point there supposed to be a
narrator Alan Watts like narrates this
game I kind of love how messed up this
damage it's really open you have like 50
lines if this people's not helping you
figure out what this game is supposed to
be Oh like it's not very unhelpful yeah
extremely helpful and I can't eat
anything and I can't I've got like 50
lions and I can't eat this thing but
you're putting this those elk through
like such emotional what does this do
whoa oh this is everything we have all
of the fortune cookies all of the
fortune cookies God is there a game I'll
give you ten high fives you know who
bi-lo is mega mr. Victor I don't know
who bi-lo is never became a harvest
master in the original I heard there's a
glitch I calculates the amount of
produce you make and more work and give
you a lower score oh I don't know about
that
zoom hula we're not sure what the point
of this game is this is very but like I
was saying it's very Buddhist it's very
uh what if I want to be alone what if I
get tired of having all of these
mountain lions around that's a good
question
if I just want to go and like sulk and
be by myself an acid trip simulator to
k17 for sure all right I assumed that
that thing up above us was some sort of
math indicator but it's not it's just
telling me where my stick is going oh
yeah oh you're just getting my lines
left and right maybe we reached some
kind of critical mass and they all
joined together I mean the one-man giant
like organic ball of not enough things
Voltron yes I agree I agree let's both
do more Voltron and more using Voltron
as a verb yes Voltron things up have
either have you seen the power ring
film I will you I have not and I
probably will oh we talked to this dude
talk to this dude see what's going on it
put that little the stick thing over
that guy's bubble way at the left I
think the left no stragglers right there
was just a person here and now they are
gone oh man this I would love to have
heard the decision of just like let's
just let them tumble that's amazing this
game is crap the only reason watches
think it's hilarious
there we go exactly you know you can see
more of him on as his new show Tosh the
game show um so so season 1 done so now
are you nervous about the premiere
oh god this is you man you're the face
of this this is this is all you well
another thing that should be noted is
like networks with real viewer ships
aren't letting people who look like yeah
you're like we're talking about our
foreheads are huge so I think it's bad
take a step back and really look at
things I think you deserve to be on
television being a star but uh this is
one of the warmest springs I've ever
lived this is about global warming is
this is this how to kill oh my god what
if it is I don't need more environmental
mess for my it's a baby game at least
the rocks are helpful Chris says that's
true trees suck rocks are actually
helping us out of this but no I'm very
nervous about the about the show I mean
it was super fun to make it we had a
great time there but the fear is always
that like that won't come through on the
actual show and right I mean but I don't
know I saw the trailer it seems like it
I mean in in 90 seconds it seemed like
there was a lot of fun stuff there I
hope so sometimes they just get trapped
behind
you know that's how yeah I did go
through rocks just take a hard left
around a rock you get rid of them
I don't think we learned any lessons
from the rocks and the trees I learned a
lot of important lessons from the Braco
from the rock from the rock
Dwayne the rock yes but what is the way
he that guy first of all you're in the
gym way too much the rock we get it oh
the best you ripped the best article of
all time was the one where he explained
his diet and how much cod he ate in a
day it's like half a car every day it's
insane that guy is just I I feel like
he's gotta be he's got a smell bad right
he just needs so much cod all the time
he's gonna sweat that out that's got to
come out and some kind of bodily fluid
I'd like to say of the rock if you were
watching first of all why are you get
back to the gym I would like to learn
what you smell man up the rock go on
talk to the game show season two he
would be amazing Charmy he is I love
three non tops to the game show
I have zero problems at the rock I think
he's awesome plus like he's like one of
those guys who just like if he's on a
film set he'll stop it for a second to
go over to a child who's dying yes you
know like the Jennifer Lawrence thing
like he's just he gets that he's like
famous and you know and all that stuff
and yes he's wonderful and not mad dick
is in on the joke I am right we have too
many people who are in on the joke now
and I'm tired of that I agree but not
the rock oh let's talk to this it's a
lonely rock oh we need to find another
way rock but there's the other way
my shirt does look like a seizure this
is true if you're seeing this when
you're not looking at this shirt go to
the hospital immediately
oh I figured out where the White Rock is
it's John Cena John Cena also not
another guy oh wait let's talk to that
tree Oh what thing is gonna tip what do
you think what thing is gonna tell us
how to kill stuff I I think it's gonna
be a rock I'm a tree I pressed do
anything this time guys do you think it
is possible this game where mountain
lions just roll around it might not be
the best developing I say if we don't
fit all right I'm giving this game five
more minutes you gotta send more of the
monsters there uh we could just smash
buttons and destroy things that's an
errand what are your did you feel like
gonna ascend or descending feelings are
dumb feelings are yeah this this game is
pretty nihilistic for being like full of
life
what are your origin is what are your
like foundational games where did you
start out whoa I mean we're talking I'm
old as the hills so I started on the old
commodore 64c I remember kids listen to
this hey kids on the Internet you want
to hear old person story my when I first
keeps us Robin Hood uh-huh and it was
you loaded it up there was a tape player
you could has set in and I had to load
for 40 minutes for zero minutes
that's wonder and you would play again
you get three lives and then the dude
with the flaming arrow would always kill
me and then you'd have to load it up
again cuz the whole tape had to play the
whole magnetic tape had to play oh
that's a load up the game it was hell on
earth but it made me appreciate so this
isn't so bad you know like it's one of
those this is I mean if you'd shown this
to anyone in 1989 they would be like
this is the best it's so realistic the
way the Manimal movements exactly that
was your first game
color pokemon blue my family went skiing
I stayed inside the lodge and play
pokemon blue that's a good that's an
important question in terms of cuteness
I feel like I'm a Diglett all right
that's reasonable did you play into that
Pokemon go yes it was so fun for a
period of time like it gamifying the
world around us I think is really smart
and we will see more of that agree but
was the fact that you couldn't fight
with people
yeah I agree it was like a hold the
whole Jim thing was a pain yeah you
could actually lose your stuff it's kind
of kind of sucker oh wait here we go
maybe talk to that thing over there I'm
I'm thirty seconds away from giving up
on this game blacks flying agave oh come
on
double schemes just mocking us yeah this
is it's not cool you won't even let us
kill anything it's doing the Internet's
job for it
exactly no wait putting still putting
together this thing's gonna try to kill
us I love it just sassily walks away
it's like later boom boom you are my
prey yeah exactly
alright no wait what are you let's we're
done with this we're done sorry
everything we're done we can't do this I
can't that was fun for a time I won't do
it anymore I need to I need to see
something be smashed um what are some of
your favorite touches what are some
aerial photos uh
Conan of course absolutely change the
game just even with his hair
yeah he's mostly hairstyle in terms of
Brent yeah right like old school Tonight
Show like you know like Johnny Carson
era I mean things were always going down
it was always a good time yeah I like a
mid-2000s the view Oh doing all of the
good fighting I saw so much i watch the
view every day for like five years
because when I was a researcher for
Conan
that you cut I got so [ __ ] was going
down everyday daily it was crazy it was
awesome it was great it was it was very
like WWE around a table like verbal WWE
alright here we go
this game very button smash e key real
biscuit wants to know what my favorite
Pokemon is the answer is Abra I like
Andrew best which game play first -
because we're gonna get our asses kicked
alright so - oh yeah choose your so you
could be anything this is kind of like a
throwback to like you know like a 50s
monster movie yeah will be huge you
remember rampage oh dude
yes this is like 3d rampage oh this is
great it's all stuff for the PlayStation
2 so this is this is classic exporting
be able to go like you know mantis big
man big old mantis energy and then we'll
tour these are gonna be our enemies so
I'm gonna make one dude big guy flaming
head alright maybe we'll play midtown
park do they have the Warner law you
what's really funny is I see Sam Elliot
around a lot really and also Ashley
Kutcher because they're taping the ranch
oh the building next to the commissary
so you'll just see like oh you'll be
walking to get lunch and like Ashley cut
you're a walker buyer like Sam Elliott
he's mustache by the way glorious all
right so let's hear I think these are
attacks
X's jump can you climb up the building
by hitting oh and grab stuff getting
railed already
you know I don't know my Godzilla was
okay what you think I didn't see it was
fine
I mean he saw Godzilla so big now it's
like any of those movies where it's like
there's a huge moss on a clover field
that's why would you just run away like
it's so easy to get away from Godzilla
yeah right exactly my god what's
happening
so you can if you hit X to jump you can
hit OH and then you climb up then you
hit yeah no don't grab onto a building
oh there Hoshi picks up it oh wow
you only injured myself I like that
story there you go yeah thank you but if
you press oh when you're next to a
building you'll climb up it press up
I don't know where anybody is Oh oh
there we go
endless fun this game is great by the
way oh this is like this is an
unheralded classic now we're all the
same
I'm just keeping the crap oh you got
impaled by something
I think just back just mash buttons
that's the idea just hit a punch
oh there you go so I didn't give you a
hit I'm hitting a lot of square punch
punches dudes and then and then kind of
circle the jump up
oh that's me oh ah no it's alright
I will say there's this tendency in
games now like to not have couch co-op
games because this is now I'm entailed
that's right oh yeah any other I've
heard you that you don't like what talk
show host sing oh is that a real thing
well no it's fine I just feel like with
a lot of seeing these days we have more
singing than jokes right that's true
you're coming in sings rich Irish
tradition yeah exactly uh you like you
boys having fun without me I'm not even
close to anybody right now I think it's
just computer fighting itself but I know
I just like jokes and I think if you can
have good monologue jokes yes but also
the hotel
right well you have to earn it you got
to earn this her name is that I feel
like you just have a lot of a lot of
singing on touch of
guys my ass I'm just I'm hitting you
again do it
now see we're teaming up this is great
[Music]
it's like when that yo and professor axe
finally I just saw it logan by the way
oh it's fine it's great I gotta watch it
I like Fargo this robot
make a giant robot is just so many
fishes you know well it really is gonna
end well yeah unless I guess we do have
giant robots making cars for us all the
time that's - that was only a matter of
time before they turn road right that's
true they start making crazy cars that
are killing everybody
[Music]
oh guy wait guy I don't know it's
something else what's your favorite game
of all time did you answer that oh I
think you answered any of the tycoon
game a World War Craft that's right he
answered back answer that yeah what do I
think about Justice League I don't know
are you being the superhero thing I mean
we all have to watch superhero movies
it's our job is America like however bad
they say one's gonna be I just love this
logo one right
oh my god some scorpion
but I'm done with that designer making
everything brooding and gray yeah I
agree I agree I think actually did you
have a tweet that said or did you
retweet it that was just like Turk that
turn up the color the showrunner of
superstore and love superhero movies
exactly it's just so like I think like
Marvel has done a great job with making
like those movies kind of bright fun yes
you know like like those Supriyo should
be like they're dominating our summer
box-office our Civil War and
Wow I haven't seen you yet really rich
homoerotic tension stance Sebastian
Chris evidence situation
nice slogans with budgets yeah
oh man that robot is such a dick Marvel
does have a leg up over Deadpool I
thought was fun
oh yes that was great Ryan rather like a
copy of Deadpool and guardians of the
galaxy delightful yeah
let me think Oh lighting storing that
buddy my god the way do you do a you do
a monologue on top of the game shut down
I did it at a live show but it just
wasn't enough time that's crazy I miss
it because as I said I love jokes I love
talk shows telling jokes fine we haven't
think
the lightning round
like modeling jokes very funny that's
fun 555
uncle - oh you know what that's that's
you're giving the assist the choke
assist as a person I don't want other
people to look good right sure but you
know smoke is it's your profession when
you're our host it's your job yes
exactly
how is it working on the mini project
oh the mini projects is super fun like
my achievement left for always has been
to work on a show about a sassy lady in
the city yes
and she's really great and like
learn so much about writing TV shows
like I don't want to get sick cons now
that's true
people there are often like 30 rock of
the office yes I finally killed him
that's a crazy pedigree yeah boy The
Simpsons and they're all really smart
enjoy here and I love that's awesome
they are my friends that seems like that
seems like a really that seems like a
fun office to work it yes you know it's
working for chief wouldn't spoil me when
it comes to fun offices because it was
like a thing of let's all just go play
call of duty together that's awesome
yeah
we've got a lot about to get work done a
lot of people are mourning the end of
chief war
whispers back and chat
the chef of Marvel vs. Capcom movie
[Applause]
bring jean-claude Van Damme back is we
see bison or know he was guile or
something
be quite her no no I mean Kylie Minogue
oh yeah there you go that's what you're
living for your broken teeth will remind
you of my victory if you ever want to
figure out if your child is like it's
not a perfect indicator of a high kicks
call of duty warfare we're good Jaco
wacko
we're here at guy Branum talk to sell
the game together talk show the game
show premiering an April 5th on truth
that's right yeah that's right he's
watched my television program also
follow this guy on Twitter I'm at guy
Branum got random I've been saying
brought him oh it's brand-new oh no oh
no it's ruined I'm sorry
guy Branum gotta start over oh there we
go
I feel like I want to be like I likes
the life I was leading in the mountain
lion exactly like the real s destruction
I think one lesson yeah I feel like
right exactly I think maybe we over
corrected with with the excitement
category because this is just on it's
just a little bananas I keep finding an
attacking you
I need to be more cooperative that's it
you know what it's it's a free-for-all
so feel free to you know I mean hi you
know I'm gonna try I try to not attack
our guests much as possible but that's
good that's responsible host right well
you know yeah I'm sure you to just try
it showing it as a season game player if
you were on a talk show the game child
yes what would your core strategies be
core strategy or you try to take it down
first of all I would my core strategy
initially is don't embarrass myself okay
so I what I usually fail it that because
I usually end up talking about like my
back hair problem sir you know all that
stuff embarrassing yourself can be a
great way of bringing a viral moment
it's just so easy it's just so easy it's
just so easy you would think I don't
have embarrassing stories but then you
know I drank a whole punch bowl of
tequila by myself and I left at the bar
on Friday night you know so it's one of
those things where it's full of tequila
yeah I was at the spare room and the
whole they get they serve punch bowls
there and I was like hey I've never done
this
I guess what that's not a good thing you
should you know like hey I've never done
this is not a good indicator of
something than you should
these Aquila leads to bad moments for me
yeah I'm electricity should I not be in
water but if you're already electricity
I don't know that you can get hurt I can
clearly get hurt my other core strategy
is to my parents are therapists so I
Sussex and dislikes and I go straight
for the soul like straight in okay what
do you peer into my soul here oh man see
I mean I see a lot of happiness Frank
okay you know I see you're dressed in
bright colors which is great also we're
not in a combat situation I can't you
know what I'm saying I can't get my
blood lust up no that's very fair you
know I don't you know I can't tell can't
go after I guess [ __ ] robot learn to
fly outside
that's okay please I said I've said
[ __ ] multiple times oh my god
now that they're still talking about
justice guys Ben Affleck hit me in the
back one time I put in my Instagram why
cuz I had to get I have a million weird
jobs in this show and one of them was
when the cast of Justice League was on
after they got interviewed I had to
wrangle them for a cast photo that's all
I was like guys don't leave I'm
screaming in Larry Fishburne space and
Holly I'm grabbing Holly Hunter like we
got it and then I go over the thing and
I'm talking I'm trying to tear Conan
away from gal gadot and I'm trying to
kind of do that an athlete hits me in
the back
I think cuz he wasn't paying attention
and even walk up the stairs I said huh
I'm so sorry he goes where would you
like this Batman I'm so sorry I got over
here over here who is Holly Hunter in
Justice League
ain't no shooting that was Batman vs
Superman she was a senator remember yeah
she was great she's pretty tell you a
great superhero movie related stories
you may already know this story I forget
where I heard it from but somebody asked
Viola Davis who she was playing and
whatever oh yes Suicide Squad spot and
she said Sam Jackson I'm playing Sam
that's a win that's a chance that's a
win I know it is kind of fun I will say
when we have these cash shows I've never
whoops all right fine it's all right all
right go for it
I've never obviously been in a giant
superhero movie yet yeah you only a
matter of time out of time I think we
all know but with YouTube we all have TV
shows and POW yes it's only a matter of
time before we all have Phil French
that's it that's you or you know what
you should do is maybe come well I would
see a crossover episode of talks of the
game show in like another true TV show
oh we
some cool people from other shows on we
have the guys those ants Oh then been
alive I've been Roy fan why yeah he's
great Roy I'm 19 I say everyone Sam Ben
Roy kicks ass you know you're just
responsibly like saying it in French if
everybody's really hilarious those guys
we're never saying crossover show where
we make all of the people from Ashok
impedes yes that seems compelling yes my
do it it could lead to some real
resentments yeah oh man I like real
resentments but I like to shove I like
to shy of wedges in between true
friendships it's so easy when you're on
television and you put stakes on it even
if the stakes are just like a garbage
disposal we're just like a rib eye in
mobis case or a rib eye Oh what would a
vegan rib eye Big O mushroom yeah just
it's just that it's basically just a
mushroom cut into a giant middle finger
here you go I have a quick thing about
vegan food which is I'm not gonna go
into it deeply but I've whole thing you
know like be yourself and especially
when it comes to food you know like if
you're gonna be tofu just be tough we
don't be like turkey or steak like
you're gonna be vegan you've given that
up I love it I've given it up no I love
that there's mock talk I love that the
people of China are making fixed yeah so
insane beautiful it's it's just like my
god just be yourself you know you know
food and I also will say I get weird
delight and eating food that like talks
it's like those M&M commercials like I
think about what I'm eating and I'm like
oh Riley thought that was great
I always think it's so weird that we
like to anthropomorphize food for
children yes we're like hey oh you're
McDonald's hamburger is a person exactly
and it's just like yeah you're gonna eat
its fate sounds like bang
I do
I do love eating things faces you know I
think eating the face is the best part
guys
a lot of people don't realize that well
I think everybody gets scared of like
eating things that look like they were
once alive well that's true but you know
what I all I'm saying is try it sometime
you know wonderful I bet humans
delicious you know I'm not gonna so I'm
a I'm an adventurous eater I'm like like
Christopher Columbus of culinary
delights like speaking out of somewhere
in front of me I'll booth I do wish we
had like baked tofu human flesh that's
true we're right so we could know just
like an arm I mean then that's a great
that's a million-dollar idea I want real
authentic Aztec food and that involves
some Cuban but you know what there's a
little bit of human flesh here there
sorry I broke that also like humans in
terms of do you know how many bones are
in a fish oh that is so annoying a human
just has a giant it's easy to eat around
the bones it's just we're doing
ourselves a disservice guys by not
eating human beings getting to hit that
robot with
bang that was really satisfying yeah
there are some satisfying moment I feel
angry sir
also especially the electricity guy
think you can really go to town in the
water although maybe that's not you guys
were almost almost out of time here with
guy Branum not bharanam
yes you see on that Street don't call
him God brought him no you should say
hey I have a season pass on TiVo yes you
show to talk show the game show
premiering it Pro pick on truTV at 10:00
9:00 central and mountain timers just
pick a time don't make us keep saying
mantle who is mountain time but knowing
nobody else can you just get on another
tough do you have to have it's like four
states have like a specific time like
what are you doing
there's two there are a lot of there are
a lot of forces you need that horse
demographic fear zone that's crazy
now wait a second now what's gonna
happen you shot the entire season how
many episodes 16 m16 is so many episode
it's a lot of episode while you've been
working the show of 10 years of course
we worked on the show for like three
months when we had a lot of TV almost
fun god it's a good time that's awesome
guys I think that's gonna do it forgot
bran watch his show talk show the game
thank you for coming it's it's a talk
show it's a game show it's got a bunch
of great people on it premieres April
5th of 10 9 central for you horses on
truTV and I'm sure you can catch stuff
on truTV dot-com
there's an app there's an app it's
amazing a follow him guy Branum on
twitter guy Branum thank you so much
thank you for joining and we will see
you guys next week right here at noon
that's Foucault go see you later
you